على الرغم من تحسن توقعات النمو في معظم
الدول الا ان كبار الاقتصاديين لا يزالون
منقسمين بالتساوي وبنسبه 45% بشان حدوث
ركود عالميا ام لا هذا ما ذكره تقرير
توقعات كبار الاقتصاديين 20 23 لمنتدى
الاقتصاد العالمي واوضح التقرير ان
الخبراء يستبعدون اي تداعيات كبيره على
النظام المصرفي باكمله جراء ازمه البنوك
الاخيره لكنهم قلقون بشان حدوث اضطرابات
جديده في المستقبل كما اشار التقرير الى
المخاوف بشان المفاضله بين كبح معدلات
التضخم والحفاظ على النمو الاقتصادي
76% من الخبراء يعتقدون ان البنوك
المركزيه ستجد صعوبه في السيطره على
ارتفاع الاسعار وخاصه في الدول الغربيه
90% من الاقتصاديين يتوقعون تضخما مرتفعا
او مرتفعا للغايه هذا العام في اوروبا في
حين يتوقعوا 68 منهم تضخما في الولايات
المتحده اعلى من المستوى المستهدف اما
بالنسبه للصين فالامر مختلف حيث يتوقع 14%
فقط من الخبراء ارتفاع التضخم في 20 23
تقرير منتدى الاقتصاد العالمي اكد ان
النشاط الاكثر ازدهارا سيكون في اسيا مع
اعاده فتح الاقتصاد الصيني حيث توقع اكثر
من 90% من كبار الاقتصاديين نموا معتدلا
على الاقل في كل من شرق اسيا والمحيط
الهادئ وجنوب اسيا
في اوروبا ما زال ثلاثه ارباع الاقتصاديين
يتوقعون نموا ضعيفا او ضعيفا للغايه العام
الحالي اما في الولايات المتحده كان
الخبراء اكثر تفاؤلا في مارس وابريل مما
كانوا عليه في يناير لكنهم ما زالوا
منقسمين بشان التوقعات بسبب عدم اليقين
المتزايد بشان الاستقرار المالي ومدى
التشديد النقدي من قبل الفيدرالي الامريكي
محمد زهير العربيه
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على يوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات